he's really good
point
before I leave for California I want to
briefly speak about what's happening in
Silicon Valley Bank and Signature Bank
today thanks to the quick action of my
Administration over the past few days
Americans can have confidence that the
banking system is safe
your deposits will be there when you
need them
small businesses across the country that
deposit accounts that these Banks can
breed easier and knowing they'll be able
to pay their workers and pay their bills
and their hard-working employees can
breathe easier as well
last week when we learned of the
problems of the banks and the impact
they could have on jobs of small
businesses and banking systems overall
I instructed my team to act quickly to
protect these interests
they've done that they've done that on
Friday the government regulator in
charge the FDIC took control of Silicon
Valley Bank's assets and over the
weekend it took control of signature
Banks assets
treasury secretary Yellen and a team of
banking Regulators have taken action
immediate action and here are the
highlights first all customers who had
deposits in these Banks can rest assured
I want to rest assured they'll be
protected and they'll have access to
their money as of today
that includes small businesses across
the country that bank there and need to
make payroll pay their bills and stay
open for business
no losses and I'm on this is an
important point no losses will be borne
by the taxpayers let me repeat that no
losses will be borne by the taxpayers
instead the money will come from the
fees that Banks pay into the deposit
Insurance Fund because of the actions of
that because of the actions that our
regular has already taken every American
should feel confident that their
deposits will be there if and when they
need them second the management of these
banks will be fired
if the bank is taken over by FDIC the
people running the bank should not work
there anymore
third investors in the banks will not be
protected
they knowingly took a risk and when the
risk didn't pay off investors lose their
money that's how capitalism works
and fourth there are important questions
of how these Banks got into circumstance
in the first place
we must get the full accounting of what
happened and why those responsible can
be held accountable
and my Administration no one in mine no
one is above the law
and finally we must reduce the risk of
this happening again
during the Obama Biden Administration we
put in place tough requirements on banks
like Silicon Valley Bank and Signature
Bank including the Dodd-Frank law to
make sure that the crisis we saw in 2008
would not happen again
unfortunately the last Administration
rolled back some of these requirements
I'm going to ask Congress and the
banking Regulators to strengthen the
rules for banks to make it less likely
this kind of bag failure would happen
again and to protect American jobs and
small businesses
look the bottom line is this Americans
can rest assured that our banking system
is safe
your deposits are safe let me also
assure you we will not stop at this
we'll do whatever is needed on top of
all of it let's also take a look at a
moment to put the situation in a broader
context we've made strong economic
progress in the past two years we've
created more than 12 million new jobs
more jobs in two years than any
president has ever created in a single
four-year term
unemployment is below four percent for
14 straight months
to go and pay for workers is going up
especially for lower and middle income
workers and we've seen record numbers of
people apply to start new businesses
more than 10 million of them more than
10 million applications over the last
two years starting businesses now we
need to keep the program this progress
going
that's what Swift action that my
Administration over the past few years
is all about protecting depositors
protecting the banking system protecting
the economic gains we've made together
for the American people
thank you and God bless you and may God
protect our troops see in California Mr
President what do you know right now
about why this happened and can you
assure Americans that there won't be a
ripple effect do you expect other Banks
to fail Mr President
should all depositors be protected at
all banks